[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
quiero comenzar haciéndoles a todos
ustedes una pregunta que es lo más duro
que les ha tocado vivir
y cuál fue su actitud
en mi caso fue la resiliencia una
historia de vida para los que no saben
lo que es la resiliencia es el el poder
saltar los obstáculos que la vida te
pone
les cuento mi historia esos dos señores
que ustedes ven en pantalla josefina y
antonio
se casaron y se casaron hace muchos años
atrás tuvieron más de 30 años de casados
nunca pudieron tener hijos él era un
inmigrante libanés que llegó a este a
este país buscando salir de la guerra y
huyendo de la guerra
cuando llegó decidió que tenía que
casarse le pregunto unos amigos y ahora
qué hago con quién me caso
los amigos dijeron andan al convento de
la uci que hay una señora una señorita
que quiere hacerse monja convence la y
cásate con ella el rápidamente se fue la
uci después de chocolates flores y
versos de amor la convención
ella dejó los hábitos y se casó con ella
ella es una mujer sumamente espiritual
él un hombre que quería comerse el mundo
que venía de la guerra que quería salir
adelante
muy terrenal
como les decía tuvieron muchos años de
casados nunca pudieron tener hijos
se divorciaron
y luego fue a líbano a visitar a sus
parientes y encontró debajo de un árbol
a una niña preciosa una niña rubia linda
que gateaba por ahí esa niña era yo por
si acaso
y dijo esta es la niña que tengo que
llevarme al ecuador para que acompañe a
josefina josefina en una mujer que había
perdido a sus padres
a su madre cuando nació a su hermano a
los 11 años y a su padre a los 12 años
era una mujer completamente sola y él de
alguna manera tenía este cargo de
conciencia de dejar esta señora sola
entonces convenció a su sobrina que era
mi mamá de líbano para que pudiera
traerle esa foto que ustedes ven allí es
una foto original del día de mi llegada
que es el día que comenzó mi residencia
fui trasladada por tres días en manos de
una azafata del iban de ecuador
con una cesta de manzanas y una muda de
ropa
sin saber a dónde iba
sin hablar el idioma a un mundo
completamente extraño y desconocido
cuando esta señora la azafata llego
aterrizó se dio cuenta que en el
aeropuerto no había nadie esperando en
la niña nadie
empezaron a buscar en la guía de
telefónica y encontraron a un turba y lo
llamaron inmediatamente se acercó al
aeropuerto esta mujer tuvo que [ __ ] el
avión e irse pues con el alma en un hilo
porque no sabía con quién dejado en esta
niña si la niña había llegado a su
destino final
en fin
la persona que me iba a adoptar mi papá
que les enseña la foto no estaba en el
ecuador se había ido de viaje
fui a casa de estos tíos que me
recogieron en el aeropuerto y cuando
llegó una semana después me llevó a casa
de su ex esposa
como les contaba una mujer espiritual
era una mujer muy buena pero que ella
nunca había recibido cariño y de tal
manera tampoco sabía darlo
esta niña aterrorizada sin hablar el
idioma con una comida diferente con
una vida diferente
tuvo que de alguna manera acostumbrarse
este a esta nueva vida
así que si pasó el tiempo
recibiendo cariño de una forma diferente
de una forma de tenerme bien vestida de
tenerme bien cuidada de tenerme bien
alimentada
pero sin el roce
crecer así es un poco difícil pero lo
hice seguí adelante llegué a este país
con un nombre raymond janine rayet
turbay y mis padres en ecuador era
torbay acevedo ahí comienza un nuevo
obstáculo los nombres era terrible
porque todos me conocían de una manera y
en mis papeles aparecía de otra
era casi que el bullying en el colegio
porque todos los chicos se burlaban cada
vez que decían raymond rachel yo no
quería levantar la mano qué susto
tampoco había una fecha de nacimiento
habían cinco fechas de nacimiento
entonces era un poco crecer sin
identidad y eso es bien difícil no saber
cuando naciste es no tener un indio un
idioma verdadero no tener unos padres
verdaderos era toda una complicación
realmente
crecí paso el tiempo
me casé
y empecé a formar algo que siempre quise
tener una verdadera familia
fue difícil como todos los que tenemos
familias saben que formarla no es fácil
y llegó el momento en que yo tenía
que ir a líbano que ir a conocer a mis
padres
mi esposo me acompañó en este primer
viaje llegamos
y me encontré con dos señores mayores
que por supuesto lloraban a mares habían
tenido una vida durísima una vida de
guerra con unos hermanos siendo aquí
hija única ya tenía seis hermanos todos
con las secuelas de la guerra era una
cosa terrible
verlos así y al mismo tiempo yo le daba
gracias a dios porque a mí me habían
escogido para tener una vida mejor
encontré a una hermana cuatro años mayor
que yo con el pelo completamente blanco
la cara completamente cuarteada y
pregunté por qué esta mujer tiene esa
cara que le pasó y me dijeron ella
huyendo de la guerra cogió a sus dos
hijas la subió en un bote y cuando iban
en el bote en altamar dos hijas se le
cayeron al agua y no pudieron parar a
recogerlas porque las bombas seguían
cayendo en el mar
y yo decía dios mío no puedo creer
gracias señor a mí no me pasó nada de
esto con tanta suerte que cuando ella
llega al refugio una semana después se
entera de que otro bote que había ido
atrás había recogido a estas dos niñas
las habían llevado a otro refugio y
luego habían encontrado a sus padres
pero en esa semana la cara se le
cuestión y el pelo se le puso blanco
imagínense ustedes historias de guerra
son terribles
luego apareció un tío que yo había
prohibido por si acaso que todo el mundo
llorará porque los libaneses somos muy
sensibles lloran mucho y el encontrarse
con esta niña después de 40 años pues
les provocaba llanto a todos y les dije
no quiero a nadie llorar yo he venido
aquí a estar feliz a que todos estén
contentos yo no quiero llantos y lo
entendieron bien
- un tío que se apareció por ahí gritaba
y me decía mírame el cuello mira el
cuello lees el intérprete que tiene en
el cuello que le pasa este señor
resulta que este señor en el que había
ido al aeropuerto a entregarme y decía
que tenía las marcas que yo le había
dejado en el cuello como una niña de dos
años puede dejarle marcas a un señor en
el cuello os es imposible las marcas
estaban en su alma y en la sentida de
esa manera
estas historias son fuertes
son terribles yo siempre decidí que mi
actitud era la que me iba a sacar
adelante que a mí nada de esto me iba a
a detener es que nada de esto me iba
a frenar que yo tenía que ser una
persona feliz y que tiene que ser una
persona agradecida
regresa al ecuador seguía con mi familia
y pasó el tiempo y esa foto no les conté
lo que pasó en esa foto
fue el último día que estuve con mi
madre biológica y me senté con ella y le
dije
quiero que sepas que lo que tú hiciste
fue un gran acto de amor que si yo
hubiera tenido que hacer lo mismo y que
hubiera estado en guerra ahora que soy
madre y te lo entiendo perfectamente
haría exactamente lo mismo el poder
salvar a un hijo entregándolo es el acto
de amor más grande que un ser humano
puede tener
regresa al ecuador como les decía a mi
madre aquí la abrace más que nunca y le
dije gracias gracias por haberme traído
gracias por haberme cuidado
porque tuve una suerte no todo el mundo
tiene esa suerte pero también había esta
actitud siempre de amor de
agradecimiento que yo creo que es lo que
a uno lo inspira y lo lleva
no pasa a la siguiente
pasaron los años
y hubo un segundo viaje al líbano
mis padres ya de 92 y 94 años los vi
ya muy mayores entonces con mi esposo
decidí tengo que regresar una vez más a
despedirme de ellos
mis hijos me acompañaron y también mis
nietos y fue una fue un encuentro
maravilloso porque mis nietos que no
conocían estos dos señores se lanzaron
como ustedes ven en las imágenes
abrazarlos y era una forma de decirles a
ellos que sin haber vivido con nosotros
sin haber sido estar en el día a día
fueron parte de nuestras vidas siempre y
no creo que haya un acto de amor más
grande
que ese de ahí que el que los niños
puedan dar algunas personas que no
conocen que simplemente conocían el
cuento
la despedida fue terrible para ellos y
para mí
me dio mucha pena esto pare ancianitos
desgarrados
pero la vida sigue y uno tiene que mirar
para adelante y esa ha sido siempre mi
actitud
porque es la única forma es la única
forma de seguir y salir los días que
estuvimos ahí hubo un almuerzo con toda
esta familia
y se paró una señora que hablaba inglés
y me dijo tu madre quiere decirte algo
yo dije que me va a decir es que miedo
me dijo
ella ha estado enferma ha estado durante
tres semanas en cama y cuando se enteró
que venías se levantó
para verte porque sabía que era la
última vez y que ya podía morir en paz
imagínense ustedes esto
para mí fue desgarrador o sea yo que soy
me considera una persona fuerte dura
tuve que salir de ahí y no pude
realmente parar de llorar
porque era jefe y era fuerte
y luego vino pues la despedida una vez
más la despedida definitiva
y
regresé con mis hijos con mis nietos
con la conciencia tranquila y con la paz
en el alma de haber hecho lo correcto de
haber ido de haber dado amor de haber
dado perdón de tener una reconciliación
y lo que les puedo decir es que para mí
ese es el triunfo del amor ese era mi
meta en la vida la conseguí con mi
familia
la conseguí conmigo mismo porque no he
llevado cargas siempre he ido con una
mochila ligera
por ahí hoy alguna vez que piedra que no
rueda acumulamos yo no iba a acumular de
ninguna manera
y pienso que en la vida uno tiene que
liberarse de las cosas uno no puede no
puede andar acumulando porque con eso
uno no avanza y uno la vida tiene que
avanzar pase lo que pase no importa no
importa si tu historia es la más fuerte
si tu problema es el peor siempre tienes
que seguir adelante siempre sin mirar
atrás siempre sacando lo positivo lo
bueno los que no tienen el alma
entonces
termino diciéndoles
qué es lo más duro que les toca vivir y
cuál va a ser su actitud
gracias
[Aplausos]